Britain's embattled Prince Andrew made a
rare public appearance on this Christmas
morning he was seen walking with his
brother Prince Charles attending an
early church service Andrew did not
attend a later service with Queen
Elizabeth and other members of the royal
family
Charlotte Gallagher with our partners at
the BBC is covering the Royal Christmas
wrapping up a year that the Queen
described as quite bumpy good morning
from Sandringham where the royal family
are enjoying their traditional Christmas
Day service in the church behind me and
they'd been huge speculation about which
members of the royal family would attend
today Prince Philip the Queen's husband
he's just been released from hospital
and he didn't come to church today
Prince Andrew the Queen's son with all
the headlines and rumours surrounding
his friendship with the convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein
he wasn't here either but we did see two
of the youngest Royals Prince George and
Princess Charlotte bear the eldest
children of Prince William and Catherine
they did come to the church today for
the first time and there was huge
excitement when the crowds of people saw
them arriving lots of photos being taken
people even handing them presents the
Queen has described this year as bumpy
and there have certainly been negative
and positive headlines about the royal
family but hundreds of people queued
from the early hours of this morning to
see them so it just shows here in
Britain at least their popularity
remains high Charla Gallagher BBC News
for CBS News Sandringham
you